[Applause]
welcome to another serving it's like
here's what we'll be bringing you in the
next ten minutes or so Angela looks at
the technology being child to help
support people living with dementia I
find out whether Microsoft's most
powerful games console really is the one
and Simon's feeling the need for speed
in our games review I've come to
Microsoft in London this week to get a
look at the company's newest offering
one that everyone has been talking about
coming up a little bit later on first
though let's get a quick look at the
tech stories that have been making
headlines this week Facebook's launched
a person-to-person payment service in
the UK allowing users to instantly send
money back and forth on their mobile
phones or computers Messenger is due to
roll out its new payment function over
the coming weeks
Twitter's trial of doubling its
character limit to 280 is being expanded
to most countries the increased word
space won't be rolled out to those who
communicate in Chinese Japanese or
Korean though those languages are able
to convey more in an individual
character English heritage has teamed up
with Google Streetview to showcase
historic sites online for the first time
the technology will allow 360 degree
views of some of England's most famous
sites and here's a new way to explore
the Great Pyramid of Giza without even
going to Egypt a team that recently
discovered an unknown void inside the
ancient landmark using imaging
technology has set up a virtual reality
research lab in Paris letting people
have a go at walking around inside the
pyramid now a project underway to see
how Internet of Things technology can
help increase support for people with
dementia Angela's been to meet some of
those involved to find out more right
John Edwards was diagnosed with
Alzheimer's disease in June 2015 a
former airline training pilot he suffers
with mild to moderate dementia John and
his wife Mary Ann volunteered to test a
new technology which could help make
life easier for them by connecting them
remotely to support
since becoming part of the study earlier
this year the couple have been using a
variety of devices such as sensors and
trackers using the so-called Internet of
Things they're placed around their home
or worn so that NHS clinicians can
monitor John's health and safety from
elsewhere it's really great because you
can then go out safely I mean John will
say oh I go out to my car at ease
knowing that I can leave him and he'll
be monitored 24/7 which is really good
very lucky really because it it's just
oh you've got a doctor's surgery yes all
for yourself yes and they're monitoring
you all the time and anything goes wrong
you can just pick up the phone very good
the technology analyzes the physical
data entries recorded by the couple each
day and keeps track of certain things
like blood pressure hydration and
temperature the sensors and devices
feedback information in real time so
that monitoring staff can see whether
someone has wandered too far from home
had a fall or is becoming unwell the
doctor overseeing the scheme is pleased
with the early indications we know that
the data that we've collected has been
really important in making decisions
about health care interventions if
something goes wrong machines already
learning a lot about people's normal
patterns of behaviour so clearly picks
up when things start to deviate when
that happens we get an alert that's
flagged at our monitoring center and
that alert is both a visual alert and an
auditory alert so it tells us to pay
attention there's something's happening
here the study being led by Sir Ian
borders NHS trusts and funded by the
Department of Health comes to a close in
March 2018 it's hoped the new way of
delivering care for people with
long-term and complex health conditions
will eventually be rolled out nationally
and for the opportunity to use the
technology applied more broadly don't
hold on really
Angela bond Sky News
time now to talk about this if you've
never heard of an Xbox one X in fact if
you've never played a videogame don't
switch over here's what you need to know
the Xbox one X is the latest games
console made by Microsoft which has been
bringing out various updates of the Xbox
since 2001 the company's got a famous
rivalry with Sony's PlayStation consoles
the two go back a long way if you've
ever heard of the console wars people
are usually referring to them and Sony
has recently been winning that war for
this week Microsoft launched its
brand-new offering the Xbox one X
promising to be the world's most
powerful gaming console it's got six
teraflops of power so my first question
for the UK and Ireland boss was that
obviously what does six teraflops mean a
teraflop is really simply a way of
measuring speed in a computer and the
fact that we have six of them means that
we have 40% more powerful than the next
most powerful console on the market so
it's one of the ways that we measure it
as the world's most powerful console now
for the bit where I bring in a gaming
expert to tell us what he thinks at the
new console meet Tommy T triple 9
showing me how to speed around the track
at serviced and just pushed me into the
wall I did I did
people seem to like hearing what time
thinks his YouTube channels been watched
over a hundred million times so what
does he make of the world's most
powerful console very very impressed the
the games that are there so if you look
at something like Forza for instance
from a driving game perspective the 4k
quality that you're now getting if
you've got that right 4k Ultra HD TV is
really making sure that everything pops
out at you Harvey tells me in four years
time it's expected half of TV households
will have a 4k screen at home but if
you're not joining the 4k explosion why
would you buy the new premium console
this is technique actually that we call
super sampling and super sampling
essentially what that's doing is it's
taking a superior resolution of image
in ultra 4k and it's shrinking it down
for the HD screen even if you have a
standard HD screen you're still going to
see improvements every bit of
enhancement counts in the console wars
the companies competing with Sony's ps4
Pro remember they're basically doing it
to try and regain some ground and regain
ground with a certain segment of the
audience who are very core gamers one
final bit of essential information about
the new Xbox one X is that it's not
cheap it's four hundred and forty nine
pounds I'm sure that'll help you decide
whether or not to buy it so now that
you're clued up on consoles let's talk
about games Simon is in the studio this
week and if you're gonna get an Xbox one
X he's got some titles you can play on
that to need for speed payback for the
ps4 PC Xbox one and Xbox one X is the
latest iteration in the Need for Speed
franchise on I'm going to tell you this
it's wonderful to have it back because
for some reason in the video game
industry as of late a lot of developers
and a lot of publishers have been
focusing on the simulation racer and
that's fine there is something cool
about getting behind the wheel of an
in-game Porsche and it feeling like a
real port however that's not as fun as
an arcade racer where you sit behind a
super powered mega car and you just go
really fast and you take corners at
breath neck speeds
Need for Speed payback takes this idea
even further it does put you in an
open-world environment and the whole
time it just keeps saying hey why don't
you go faster
hey why don't you go faster and that is
why it's really fun you're essentially
in an action movie
you're the stunt driver and I'm sure if
they had the license they would have
just called this The Fast & Furious the
game because that's what it's all about
if you've been wanting for an arcade
racer that's just fun entertaining and
exhilarating need for speed payback is
it probably go and get it okay boys
supera Lucky's tale for the PC Xbox one
and the Xbox one X is the sequel to
Lucky's tale that came out a few years
ago and it is one of the most laid-back
relaxing platformers you could ever hope
to play it kind of feels like one of
those games that would have come out in
the late 90s from a Nintendo 64 but
there's nothing wrong with that because
if you're looking for a nostalgic treat
Super Lucky's tale is exactly this and
it's just a very relaxing game that you
should really play with your family or
play with your kids if you're having
your lazy Sunday and you just want to
chill out and relax use your play Super
Lucky's tale it's never gonna challenge
you but it is gonna relax you and make
you feel pretty good
so yeah Super Lucky's tale isn't really
gonna push your brain in any significant
way but sometimes you don't want that
sometimes you do just want a kind of
nothing experience that when you're done
you think that was nice that's exactly
what super lucky spell is
Fire Emblem warriors for the Nintendo
switch takes the Fire Emblem series then
it takes the dynasty Warriors series it
pushes them together and this creation
is what comes out the other side and
you'll be pleased to know well it's
really entertaining given the two
franchises that it is based on that
doesn't mean you're gonna be hacking and
slashing literally hundreds of enemies
that are on screen but the cool thing
here is the role-playing elements from
Fire Emblem have also been added into
the mix so why do get to go around with
a big sword and just attack things you
can also level up your characters and
there's a cool story to make sure it
keeps progressing over nicely so really
this does do exactly what it says on the
tin it takes Fire Emblem it takes
dynasty warriors it makes both
franchises work and the result is a very
good video game that you can get now on
your Nintendo switch thank you for
watching as always I'll be back with
more swipe next week and in the meantime
follow us on Twitter ask a new spike bye
bye
you
[Applause]